my name is Jay Weininger I'm a community
college teacher bath teacher and I'm
here to share with you my efforts to
introduce we're from researches products
to my colleagues that required me to
become somewhat proficient in the
language and I have examples I want to
show you and also to come up with a
definition of computational literacy
that will ring true with my colleagues
thank you
after a computer career spending
customer support program in sales I
joined a faculty at a community college
as a math instructor with 43% of our
liberal arts students failing algebra
community colleges need an alternative
I've been there 10 years and I've
watched the same process over and over
again
obviously Wolfram Alpha and Wolfram
language are that those internal
alternatives in order to introduce the
potential of the software to my
colleagues I became proficient to the
extent that I could demonstrate its
impact on students performance and
creativity I will share the details of
my learning process with you and I'll
point out the slides but it's it's more
of okay for each of the four discussed
areas being database queries
computational essays system models and
programming paradigms
I will provide coding examples
highlighting their impact on student
creativity the first example let me
gonna get it right here you can is is
the arrow you can see the arrow okay the
first example concerns a medical
question if done gay fever spread to
Florida how many Floridians would be
infected if you notice the first query
which I didn't expand provides the stats
on done gay fever the second query well
from alpha query informs us of the
Florida's population and then the third
is the percentage of that population
that would be infected which comes out
to about seventeen thousand four hundred
cases so that's a medical simple a
straightforward medical example of using
the database queries
what did I learn from this
you see the queries are very specific
each one contributes to the overall
results so you can't get too too too
much into a query
okay so we're from language provided a
query example based on Van Gogh's
artwork the famous one now let's see if
I can get to it give me a moment
what's light in my eye whoop I went too
far I heard this based on an analysis of
ten randomly selected van Gogh's
paintings the query determined that the
artist in is canis this color palette
used very limited set of colors this
example let me let me go back up
introduced me to entities the entity
being the person van Gogh and his works
it introduced me to function specific to
the content area chromaticity to
understand this colors and notation if
you notice the as if I get to the
percent this refers back to the previous
results so I kept building and trying to
become more comfortable with this
environment
note that these this results in an
answer not in the list of articles that
you have to read that Google provides
okay let's now I have to go back up give
me a moment I'm going back up
computational essays the next excuse me
the next component provide numerous ways
for expressing your creativity this talk
utilizes calculations that we'll see as
we go along you've already seen query
results you've seen images and document
formatting sets as the title of this
next slide the two queries show the
range of content accessible to your
essays from a community college
perspective each department has access
to its disciplines data so I learned
when I will talk to the colleagues to be
very specific to their area and and not
go overboard with the potential in
Wolfram language and Wolfram Alpha
so that's competition I says our liberal
arts students need a non mathematical
tool for study nonlinear complex systems
that too will be an agent-based modeling
fortunately Wolfram language works
seamlessly with one sense to tool net
logo from Northwestern let me get to it
what do you look in here the coding that
demonstrates how Wolfram language and
net logo work together and by
integrating I mean the models output
will be graphically visualized and
Wolfram language because when I go back
home that's what I'm gonna start working
on becoming more becoming aware and more
proficient with the graphics capability
and Wolfram's language
by defining the behaviors and
interactions of the agents independent
of higher mathematics our liberal arts
students can study these complex systems
which are among the unsolved problems of
the 21st century so you can see from
this talk I'm interested in working with
the liberal arts students who may not be
as comfortable mathematically as we'd
like but to give them an environment
where they can be creative our stems -
I'm sorry if anyone wants to say
something as we go along it's fine our
stem students use differential equations
in their studies supported by Wolfram
researches system modeler
I have to go down to second I always
lose worth errorless it's terrible where
is it there is as surely I'm pointing
that won't help you why can't I do this
paratis is showing in these last two
paragraphs net logos models overlap with
Wickham language databases this ensures
a productive synergism they work
together here comes the harder part
since these two programming paradigms
functional and rule-based provide that
calculational aspect of your creativity
they need to be understood I will
explain my learning process for grasping
them let's see in the me go down first
right right here I wrote a procedural
programming in other words with looping
and indexing calculating permutations it
included my first let me get to a
functional statement identified right
right here why is it functional if you
notice one of its parameters is another
function so the functions are nested
second this notation slash ampersand
applies that the two string to every
element in my item so that helped me
start and be comfortable with functional
statements but truth-in-lending I had to
call the support group to get me started
okay so let's keep going why do I keep
losing this okay we'll go to the next
next I studied a non-trivial
implementation of a single random walker
or Tomita developed by Gaylord and nish
state I mean
Nisha date this is not my coding this is
their kollene why did I pick it good
question I picked it because the code
uses the rule-based paradigm with its
walk you can see at the walk statement
how do rules work when the left-hand
side of the rule in this case the these
five digits match the pattern being
examined the right-hand side replaces
that expression also notice that the
rule has many variations of arguments as
multiples medic d'you see them as many
rules and like functions can be nested
what does that mean if you notice the
right-hand side of these four rules
capital R and D let's see what that
leads to that we have to go up we go up
here is the rule that the rnd references
and it applies a random integer between
1 & 4 to the site but I'm not trying to
talk about the automata I'm trying to
talk about the learning process that I
worked hard on to become comfortable
with the functional and rule-based
paradigms
laughter but now I need to go to another
slide I'm going to get to another slide
I use the software as my instructor to
analyze smaller chunks of the code so
what do I mean by that whatever is
happening here you see initial
configuration
well that is computed can I see it where
is my initial configuration one second
oh right here
this map thread function which is highly
nested computes the initial config so
let's go to slide 10 if I can get there
whoop I'm already there
you're right you can't understand the
details of this because I took a month
study nnessee the converted converted
configuration is computed in another
nested function so I try to you I did
not try
I used Wolfram language to help me
understand the chunks making up the
nested like nest the nested functions
this effort reinforced that the lists
are the foundational datatypes of the
Wolfram language with all other formats
sets of matrices tables vectors derived
from them and it's very understand what
chunk of the list you're working on are
you working with the whole list are you
working with the sub list are you
working with the elements in the sub
list and that's where the level specs
become so important you have to
understand those and that took a little
bit of effort
where's next finally the last step if
you remember I wrote a procedural
version of the program and I wanted to
end up with a functional version of the
program using the using the the
functional paradigm functional
programming paradigm you won't remember
but the initial exercise have ten or
twelve statements now it gets reduced to
my step and if dictionary word Q etc so
I worked very hard to go for my
background as a procedural programmer to
using the paradigms that are fundamental
to programming and Wolfram's language so
what did I take away from this Wolfram
language supports your your creativity
with this creative functions I mean this
is unbelievable form from my background
as a procedural programmer this in turn
requires you thinking about your coding
to match that for example my an initial
effort you can see the difference a
comma one whatever this means a comma
one and two I should have realized that
if all
manipulates the collection why couldn't
I have the second parameter also
manipulate that aspect of the list I
don't know why I didn't see that but to
be fair to the support group they told
me so I had all one or two or three
ridiculous they said use a comma all so
you have to change your thinking now
maybe you're better off if you never
program because then you won't have the
wrong instincts for this environment I'm
repeating the point the functional
paradigm works with groups collections
that I'm saying this again that could be
the entire list that could be the sub
lists making up the list that could be
the elements in that sub list that's
where those level specs are so important
because it locates your processing on
that part of the list that you're trying
to manipulate so I have to go back up
bear with me I'm going back up don't
know am I going up oh here it is
after this brief overview but what we
overview we overviewed database queries
computational essays my interest in
modeling because I want to become better
at the graphics capability and then the
programming paradigms so what I'd like
you to do to revisit your school
experience so as you can see right here
I don't mean to read you imagine if you
could could use Wolfram Alpha to answer
your own questions about the topic your
studied in school imagine creating the
computational essay and presenting that
to your classmates imagine participate
in studies of complex systems without
feeling mathematically inadequate
imagine your satisfaction of completing
a study structured with functional and
rule-based coding so I worked hard to
have that ik that that those imagination
is fulfilled all these processes
contribute to your computational
literacy being your creative efforts
with their incremental achievements you
notice I showed you the the permutation
program starting from procedural and
ending up with a very contents condensed
version of it based on what the
functional paradigm
well I'm trying to emphasize at least
with my colleagues at where I teach in
Gainesville Florida
that it's better to talk about student
performance and enhancing their
creativity than it is to discuss
computational literacy because then what
happens they immediately step back and
say oh your math ooh
you want me to program so it may be
better to be very specific to that
colleagues domain start with the
database queries that I'm not one Pete
myself and and and build up to the
computational aspect of of what wolfram
offered well from research offers us
because I've tried for many years to to
deal with the issue and I think that I
say it then I skip over that we front
43% of our students here after year in
their algebra courses well as I said
will from research offers some an option
alternative to that what's the point of
doing that okay so I did there I'm
almost done I'm not doing badly what
time is it now
oh they were doing well good way to have
questions now this Scylla a little
overdone but before we hope we exchanged
because I'm very happy to get your input
I'll end with a syllogism you can see it
my my brilliant syllogism tools I'm why
am i reading to you tools enhance our
creativity computational literacy is a
supersized tool there for computational
literacy super-sizes our creativity and
I think that's the takeaway and that's
the way I think you need to deal with
your colleagues at a community college
don't talk about computational literacy
now as an aid to our discussion but I
hope we have exchange bring up the
summary slide that will forget about the
first part the database - computation
the modeling and the paradigms so we've
just completed five months of effort
your turn